year or two of the single cup it's like
the most epic thing ever what a memory
to be able to relive something that was
just simply something Ben I see again in
another 3035 years exactly the 2014
Sinquefield cup famous for Fabiano Cara
Juana
7'o streak we were watching it in the
booth and it's like each round we were
like okay this is gonna stop soon when
is you know when is he just gonna make a
draw like a normal person and he just
kept coming with these dazzling
victories I think the memory maker for
me to start off was the victory against
Magnus Carlsen of course the world
champion with the black pieces that
night d3 was monstrous it was a complex
game of course Magnus didn't have to
lose his game but probably just kept
upping the ante with vicious
calculations and then finally coming up
with moves that Magnus cracked at the
end but the force of play by Fabi was
remarkable I mean every game was coming
who's winning a different way he played
a novelty in his game against MVL when
MVL decides to play a coward con and
then he walks right into a a bomb and
then he beats Magnus this this complex
way it was remarkable to see how he was
doing it it's true I mean actually garry
kasparov in commenting on this
tournament said that what was so
remarkable about fabi's result was not
only they had setna or which of course
is astronomical but also that he wasn't
benefiting from massive howlers from his
opponents they weren't blundering he was
just winning in incredible ways and each
way different in round four he about
beat Levon Aronian in a maneuvering game
that Fabi later said was one of his
favorite games of all time I think
Christian called it the best game he's
ever seen which is pretty cool and also
you make this point I mean he won in so
many different ways his opponents were
laudatory they were all all of them
saying this is unbelievable they were
basically playing for a second place and
they could see it and they couldn't stop
it and Magnus himself who could never
even imagine giving up in a tournament
started feeling the force of fabi's
amazing play and he was quite
congratulatory about it he's very
respectful towards Fabi in fact he kind
of Prasad's the world championship match
that they would play a few years later
because it was like yeah he's the guy
he's the guy to beat I mean besides me
of course
alright and another great game of course
a he beat Veselin Topalov and dazzling
sacrificial style he being Maxime
Basharat for the second time in the
tournament in a really bizarre game
where it was like a normal symmetrical
position but Maxine's King was on c3 and
finally he ended up stopping the streak
in round 8 but he had already clinched
the tournament well he kind of was
playing as Magnus so it would have been
very hard to just keep running although
he did have a good position against
Nakamura in round 9 that essentially was
a winning game but after you're already
+7 against this field
let me that's completely ridiculous one
thing I remember was his 7 wins were
equal to the entire tally of 7 wins for
the rest of the field which included
Magnus Magnus's wins which included
lavon's wins and I think only one win
from from mvl and and T'Pol off with
naka not scoring anyway and so since I
mean you about yourself basically lapped
the field that field is astonishing and
to me it also really looking back on
that tournament it puts in perspective
Fabiano the Fabiano factor in the United
States after that tournament he switched
Federation's to us chess but it kind of
felt like this was an inspiration for
that he felt at home in st. Louis
the city and the country really started
to get to know Fabiano who was born here
but spent much of his professional chess
life before that in Italy playing for
Italy and he I remember played in the
burning boards exhibition and that was
so much fun Maurice we all played
against a different artist who did you
play president almond maybe yes French
Stallman that is or played Francis my
owner
gallery owner in New York that's exactly
who I played playing on those chess
boards or the candles burning and you're
true they're trying to remember the
positions what pieces are what and there
were actually some pretty decent games
that didn't ever getting played in
memorable games in fact that no getting
played too regular doing the burning
boards it was a stunning exhibition I
see made the pairings so Fabiano played
against an artist Livia leaf on OVA and
that game was actually a draw so
actually his first draw in the
Sinquefield Cup was in the burning
boards exhibition because he was kind
enough to get the draw of course exactly
a major gentleman on the board and of
course totally the ruthless racking up
7-0 the artist there Glenn keine played
against Magnus Carlsen and Magnus his
second visit to st. Louis not quite as
memorable as his first of course and
that he did not win the tournament but
remember that when he came in 2014 he
came as a world champion also didn't Rex
just brutally wipe out his opponent in
that one form of technical
he was unforgiving the candles didn't
even start burning it was already
checkmated his opponent and he had no
mercy whatsoever what are you teaching
this guy well I think you know he wanted
he wanted to win the game I mean you
can't blame Rex
chemically Rex although of course it was
an artistic exhibition so most people
like let the wax melt into these
stunning configurations and Rex is just
like forget about that get me that w but
getting back to Bobby's performance the
perspective on history it wasn't just
the same field cop coming into its own I
think that's an important point to make
that once he did that it was just
another tournament anymore it became
sort of a marker for the rest of all
time that this had been put down as
maybe the greatest single performance of
any chess player at any point in history
in a tournament agreed I think that it
was incredible and of course when you
say the greatest performance of all time
you think Fabiano caranas resolved in
the Sinquefield Cup in st. Louis now
five years later we're certainly saying
that you also might think about Bobby
Fischer strict Street but just shows you
the kind of
that Fabiano was becoming in and a few
years later he played magnets for the
World Championship and you couldn't help
but think that the Sinquefield cup kind
of predicted that you talk about Bobby
Fischer streak are you talking about the
match streak where you beat everybody in
the world championship match
no I'm talking about the US Championship
the US Championship doesn't compare
though the US Championship to to Magnus
Carlsen and and Levon Aronian these
monsters no I mean the US Championship
streak was was quite good but it could
not compare possibly to this one I think
maybe things back it was at Las Palmas
94 maybe with Garry Kasparov you know
those kind of performances Karpov I
remember winning a Linares and
incredible style it memory serves that
compares because you're talking about
the elite of the elite this was a 2802
rating average it was a highest-rated
tournament of all time in 2014 at that
point and to go 700 against that feel
including the world champion the
reigning world champion and that's
completely ridiculous yeah and he not
only that he won the tournament so with
such a score that second place was plus
one
he was plus seven that's it's it's
outrageous
I think the only thing that's going to
match that for fabi's career ever no
matter what he does is defeating Magnus
becoming world champion I think he
really set himself up like a high
measure now that this says you've got to
become world champion he's not gonna do
better than that
it really was remarkable those of you
who weren't watching it I urge you to
relive it it's almost the kind of thing
that for me as Maurice who are calling
the games if somebody had showed us the
script that this is what's gonna happen
we would have said no this is
unrealistic you got to change it it's
impossible and what's interesting about
that you talk about a script usually
there's drama in the script right it's
like who's gonna win it comes to the
wire the finish could be a fantastic
finish but sometimes the drama is in the
excellence and in this case you're
watching someone play it such an elite
level level almost computer esque
angelic that you're mystified just
watching are in awe like
what is going on that this guy is
performing at this incredible level the
2014 Ziegfeld Cup we were really blessed
to have that tournament here and it felt
after that event that the Ziegfeld cup
had been around for decades and it was
only two years